ow
hey
hey buddy put a cup of sweet OH
then all of a sudden from out of a pond
left a dripping wet frog with the
dripping wet wand he dropped it politely
then said with a croak as the witch
tried the wand on a fold of her cloak I
am a frog must cleaners can be room on
the broom for a frog like me
well yes tried the winch so the Frog
fire down the witch tapped the
broomstick
they were gone
oh yes cooking worked extremely diverse
animation styles and anyone who wants to
feel this question go right ahead
there's there's really no order to the
answers can you tell us a bit about the
technical approach you chose and why you
felt that particular technique would
work with your specific story anos
commotio Sakima des neige money ho no mo
kasi kaoru mono mono Anita Messiah dr.
Diana CDs so to come on up the Japanese
name for possessions it talks about a
very traditional way of thinking that
they're there are lives residing in
things so called a mano doyou cikini
shoka comitato kini a non Jesus I can't
yuka songs I can gotcha gotcha Toco Toco
top 10 Arizona odo na na ryona yo
mizushima stuff so when I when I came up
with this idea I thought that it would
be fun to use sound onomatopoeia into
expressing making an animation
expressing onomatopoeia dojo Connaughton
ND root okie nadeznha yenika a terre des
neige magico italiano como I saito-san
siren des cadeaux a note samatha a no
Washee tucano yoga me to you- toca washi
Japanese people Scott a Maku Domo no
asobi dogan ishutin des cadeaux sorry
ami je ah correo de Coteau motorola
conch I know saggy nuts packages so um
so when I got this project I was
thinking what should i do in terms of
animation style and I went home and I
have one year old and a three year old
and my wife told me my wife was playing
with my kids and she was using washi
which is like a traditional Japanese
origami paper and he was like and then
that that's when I thought oh my god
this is this is what I should use in my
animation thank you
Ferrell is all hand drawn with Farrell
which was hand drawn I'm sorry that
seemed unnecessary I apologize I could
speak Portuguese Touche that's French in
the case of this film it was important
that the style had a very kind of
aggressive visceral and organic quality
to it because I wanted to make sure that
you got a sense of what was going on
inside of the child's mind always kind
of torn between two different worlds and
one of them very savage and the other
one in theory civilized but also savage
underneath so the idea of having an
image that was always changing always
shimmering always kind of shaking in a
way was very important to me for room on
the broom um we tried to find a style
that like obviously it's CG animation of
maybe not obviously when it is CG
animation and we tried to still have a
very tactile look and so that you
immediately know what kind of material
there is so what the characters are cg
animated and the backgrounds are still
and crafted sets and this combination
mate is possible to have something that
feels tactile and has some like
imperfections that make give a special
field to the film I mean the film is
based on a very popular british children
spoken the illustrations are kind of
like flat and and graphic but what we
felt like when we could take into a
third
we could really expand on the world
while staying true to the original
illustrations and you guys shut that CG
on tues right didn't you tell me that
once yeah the animation is on tues so
every second frame is a new pose and
yeah originally we thought that would
save some money but it kind of turned on
more complicated on mr. hippo we we have
made the movie as a 3d CG animation it
was impossible to made so many objects
and the world is just crazy the world of
mr. blue so we decided to make it as
with CG animation I take three years to
make mr. mr. who blew three years yeah
three years of production and intensive
production and for mr. hublot in which
3d animation we had more flexibility on
all the world and mr. hublot does exist
as a 3d version even if we have only see
as a 2d version so it was possible to do
that version with CG animation 20 for me
it's simpler I think I chose through the
3d animation because it's the only
technique I know well from it's just an
obvious choice i'm a 3d animator the
other thing with mystery blow is that
the the characters that the film is
based on our real characters they exist
as statues they do exist for real and i
think the other challenge with CG
animation is to render that grittiness
that it has because CG animation tends
to be quite polished so it was more on
the textures of the the objects and
everything so everything needed to look
quite dirty and gritty and yeah the CG
animation although it tends
to look quite clean gives you the
possibility to also make stuff look
quite dirty when you have the right
people working and I don't know what
they're doing yeah the good dirty people
yeah the dirty people 30 people uh they
exist as statues yes they're really
sculptures sculptures yeah this is a
Belgian artist who make them write his
name Stefon Alou and yeah they're even
for sale for those who are interested we
can talk afterwards and fun for you too
Dorothy yes forget a horse there's
clearly more than one technique involved
and one is all new but actually we tried
as hard as we could to make it look like
it was made 85 years ago in 1928 well
during the year of the earliest year of
Mickey Mouse Steamboat Willie and then
of course once they come out of the
screen there in your theater in our the
best we can do in CG and 3d so if you
didn't realize there were two different
techniques in that short I I the only
kindly thing I could say is maybe you
didn't have your glasses on well that
does beg the question I'm curious about
when designing a film that would take
advantage of the 3d format as you have
in its theatrical screenings yet still
work as a 2d film on home which it will
live forever on home video as all Disney
fish we planned it with no thinking that
hey here is our biggest theatrical
surprise and spectacle that we could
give somebody so we didn't actually pay
a lot of attention to what would happen
in your home really screening room so
I'm sorry if it doesn't come across well
if you just don't buy it on iTunes
interesting how the differences in the
filmmakers one's trying to sell statues
and the other after the show in a lobby
and the other saying please don't buy
well we're all different artists I think
that's important to remember I hope he's
enjoying all this um in the case of mr.
who blow and and a room on the broom we
have two directors working in
partnership and so I'm curious how
partnership works when it comes to
making a short animated film as in who
did what so we'll start here with mr.
who blow networks I got them to the
project a pretty late script was already
written Lauren decided to take me take
me on as a co-director he and Stefan
Ella had co-written the script already
for a mystery blow and so at the time
when I was involved in the movie the
script was already there there was a
couple of parts of the film that still
needed some fine-tuning the ending was
something that was going on forever we
still didn't know how to finish the film
so there was a lot of back and forth
because at the time when he contacted me
I was working in Sydney in Australia so
we started off our collaboration via
Skype and telephone and email and a lot
of back and forth he would send me the
latest real and I would just give him
feedback and then we would change things
or not depending on everybody's yeah I
don't know some sometimes it works well
together sometimes it doesn't someone's
really sometimes we disagree yeah so I
would tell them what I did did like
about the last version and he would go
like knack and change it I was like our
please change in using man i'm not sure
about this but yeah we would usually
would find in agreement some somehow and
things would work out and then did you
eventually I managed to go to Luxembourg
to work together
with him oh okay physically the sitting
room is helpful did you question often
asking him to join you I'm in making the
movie yes I mean it seems only natural
that there's going to be disagreements
when there's one leader instead of two
but as he said Alex came later on the
movie what's I said when all the work of
just just after pre-production and so it
came during a production 3d production
right to give a hand on the creation of
mr. who blow and specially during
animation and yes we both have areas of
expertise clearly that you're bringing
to the partnership so at times it was
difficult to agree at at times it was
easy i imagine i hope yes ish it was
never easy no it's not it's not it's not
always easy yeah Laurel is ya like it
like I said he was more like on the
story side he had everything figured out
he knew how the inner workings of the
character and I still had to learn him
when I got into the project I have my
own ideas of what the character was
going to be like right and so I would
anyway this scene because Leigh yeah
obviously I'm an animator I did a couple
of shots on the scene or I would
supervise somebody was animating a shot
going like that changed his change and
Lauren would be like oh no no that's not
the way I envisioned this so he would
like try to get me onto the right track
again or even scenes that I animated I
had to reanimate a couple of times
because I I wasn't getting the inner
workings of the character the way he had
envisioned them you can only be inside
your own head as it turns out I guess
yeah but it's sometimes funny when you
talk about things because I've
experienced this on a couple of other
projects that I worked and that people
say something and you will all yeah
totally get what you're saying and you
do what they say and they look at you
were gonna go like oh that's not what I
said it was like but I did get what you
said it like no no that's not it so yeah
it's it's
sometimes it's really like in the detail
you really need to ask a million times
to be really sure what the other person
means when they tell you certain things
and that's that's a great last night
often that's a great lesson for all
filmmakers so when working in a
partnership is absolutely say what the
hell you mean and room on the broom can
you shed a little more light of the
partnership and the struggles there and
we just have a few more moments we'd
love to hear from you well for us I
think it was a bit different because we
like young and I literally met at the
first day of film school and like we
worked on a lot of our student films
together so we became really good
friends doing that doing that it's time
to studying I had a shorthand when you
yeah and like we were always dreaming
about working professional league
together so when we had this opportunity
that like the first through six month of
the production there was really mostly
pre-production we were a really small
team and I'll it most of the storyboards
and young modeled all the characters and
did all the layout and once we got like
a very big team to work with that like
we made sure that we talk to each other
like several hours a day and before we
approach the artist we always made sure
we on the same page so yeah it wouldn't
give any like conflicting notes
finishing each other since and I and I
have yeah i mean i have to say it was
really when you when you're working on a
project so long and like if you alone
you yes there's a good chance you end up
a bit isolated like as a at the boss of
the big team it's really nice to share
that experience like with a really good
friend where you have a lot of trust so
to me that's what that was one of the
most rewarding experiences on working
with the film that I could do it with
with one of my best friends oh that's
nice that's very nice it really is so if
you were looking for some kind of dirt
yeah it's not he's not gonna happen over
there no you don't have no they seem to
be very very happy unlike the first
couple we talked to
it's like match game exactly what I was
make it short I was thinking honey the
honeymoon yeah so Daniel regarding
Farrell you know this great history of
Francis Truffaut the wild child and
actual feral children that he inspired
his work so I'm wondering what sort of
were there any true stories of feral
children that you studied to inspire or
that inspired you in any way yeah I
actually looked at a lot of true stories
and when the film started it was going
to be a retelling of the kaspar hauser
story which of course is a really
amazing orner Herzog film as well and I
started looking into not just that story
but a lot of other accounts of feral and
abandoned children throughout history
and I also looked at a lot of myths and
fairy tales concerning you know stolen
children or fairy children or you know
creation myths that involved that kind
of duality between man and animal and I
kind of just put it all in a pot shook
it up and made my own story out of it
that's great thank you Shuhei oh yeah
that you understand
your film possessions is part of an
anthology of animated short titled short
piece how does your film fit in with the
other shorts and what was it conceived
independently or was it always planned
to screen with the other three films
though shota pizza uh no Union no canto
de ano Scotty master a duty stowed sulla
a dose and its initial condo khorosho an
auto McCarthy rose an Akira way up till
cata this so short piece consists of
four shows and the first one is by
cotton eye joe tomo who was at the annie
awards last month last month several
months ago yeah he and that was directed
by Otto Musa Bogardus Nets como yo que
me coke on a 02 record scrotie otopeni
des neige a no go pick ETO Cassano
printout OS terre des neso pokhara
Otomo's ando con tiga detect a des neige
ma llega su NJ co mo de mas amo tacchini
azuma naka de la she could sue roto goes
nobody not a top psychic in this so just
as I was planning the my own animation
style I was standing by the copier and
then here comes Otomo storyboard which
is just amazing and detailed and that's
when I realized okay I gotta do it my
way oh it's really fantastic so you were
inspired by greatness and said I can do
better
ya know nantia day no risotto cos enact
a mo jibun de secours a note even that's
good scuba you cannot be unlocked every
mom committed it wasn't that it was more
of giving giving up you know I I knew
that I couldn't beat this guy so I
decided that it I'm just gonna have to
do it my way oh that's great that's
great fantastic I'm so sorry that we we
don't have more time to spend with these
brilliant film makers because we have of
course the live action as well we're
going to take a ten-minute break but
before we leave this stage I think one
more wildly enthusiastic round of
applause is deserve congratulations to
all of you congratulations thank you
truly and good luck you've already won
enjoy you know that's the thing you'll
be oscar nominated or Oscar winner and
then your name for the rest of your
lives and in the eventually people will
just here Oscar word your name